is that shall we have a story don't
tickle the monkey Isaac is nearly nine
years old but has the mental age of a
newborn since birth he suffered with
Alan hernd and Dudley syndrome an
incredibly rare condition that requires
24 7 care and specialist equipment
keeping the electricity on in this house
is a matter of life and death I like a
lot of parents with children that need
all this extra equipment are terrified
the equipment that we need it's not a
choice
it's
life for Isaac without the electricity
without using it
I said we die Maxine says her bills have
already gone up by 30 pounds a week I
have not
there's no way of saving any more no
I mean I've got dogs
um but I'm not going to get rid of my
dogs
because
that's my sanity
I'll just have to pay it I'll just have
to find it somehow
um probably cut back on my own food
I think
it's okay to say
um
we're working on it we'll fix it but to
leave parents in our situations until
the last minute
it's not Humane when you're thinking
about keeping your child alive
for people like Maxine they are
understandably genuinely terrified about
what's on the horizon this winter it's
why she and many others will be looking
to whoever will be the next prime
minister and the leader of the
opposition for clear and exact detail on
just what more help can be offered
the labor leader will outline his
party's plan this week but Charities say
it is the government that needs to
announce the next stages of support
problem for government that only
government can solve buying food for the
table take taking transport to important
medical appointments you know these are
the trade-offs that people are
considering having to sell Furniture
sell basic items just to be able to
continue to afford
um keeping their lights on which is
completely unacceptable
um in this day and age in a country like
the UK
vaccine in Isaac's case is Extreme but
it's a stark illustration of what Rising
costs can really mean
I'm not asking
for March I'm just asking for help with
power to keep my little boy alive
down why did Sky News in Hampshire